they did it to preserve their own power
and enrich themselves
all while rigging the system to hold
down
the good decent middle class patriots
striving to build a family
and pursue a decent life all of this
changed dramatically in 2015
when a billionaire named donald trump
put his own life of luxury on the line
from that moment he came down that
famous escalator
he started a movement to reclaim our
government from the rotten cartel of
insiders
that have been destroying our country we
may not have realized it at the time
but trump is the bodyguard of western
civilization trump was elected to
protect our families
from the vengeful mob that seeks to
destroy our way of life
our neighborhoods schools churches
and values president trump was elected
to defend
the american way of life the american
way of life
means you follow the law you work hard
you honor god you raise your kids with
strong values
and you work to create a civil society
the american way of life means you speak
your mind
without retribution without being kicked
off social media by a self-righteous
censor
in silicon valley it means you can
freely practice your religion
and that church is more essential than a
casino
and it means that we judge people on
their actions
not on their immutable characteristics
the american way of life is being
dismantled by a group of bitter
deceitful vengeful activists who have
never built
anything in their lives they have us
locking up pastors
while releasing violent criminals from
prison we are kicking
doctors off of social media yet
promoting chinese state-funded
propaganda
on major tech platforms
this election is the most critical since
1860 when a man named lincoln was
elected to preserve the union
from disintegration this election is not
just the most important of
our lifetime it is the most important
since the preservation of the republic
in 1865. by re-electing trump we will
ensure that our kids are raised
to love our country and respect its
founding fathers
not taught to hate or be ashamed of them
we will build monuments to heroes not
burn down our cities
we'll be a country that rises to higher
heights that dreams big
thinks big and achieves the impossible a
country that
values our remarkable journey the
complexities of our past
but clearly communicates to the next
generation
that we have to be grateful not
angry that we live in the united states
we will be a country that makes it
easier to have
many children live quiet and peaceable
lives
and worship your god without a tyrant
getting in the way
we will be a country that has its best
100 years ahead
we will build a future where america
remains the greatest country
ever to exist in the history of the
world all of that
is within our grasp if we secure four
more years
for the defender of western civilization
our champion
my friend the 45th president of the
united states
president donald j trump
i'm rebecca friedrichs a veteran
california public school educator
i'm here to give voice to america's
great teachers
because our voices have been silenced
for decades
by unions who claim to represent us
they do not when other dedicated
teachers and i
served within the unions we spoke up in
defense of children
parents scientific fact and american
values
for our trouble we were brutalized booed
off the platform
barred from committees shouted down
and even spit upon by union leaders
this is how unions treat devoted
teachers
but what's even worse is how their
agenda of control
deceives americans and our children
they've intentionally rewritten american
history
to perpetuate division pervert the
memories of our american founders
and disparage our judeo-christian
virtues
their lenient discipline policies
morphed our schools into war zones
and they back defunding police and
abolishing ice
unions collect billions annually from
unsuspecting teachers and push this
radical agenda
into our classrooms against our will
why the only way to keep a free republic
is with a well-educated moral citizenry
that can self-govern unions are
subverting our republic
so they undermine educational excellence
morality
law and order that's why they spend
hundreds of millions annually to defeat
charter schools
and school choice trapping so many
precious
low-income children in dangerous corrupt
and low-performing schools to fight back
on behalf of children and america brave
teachers brought a lawsuit against
unions
and do you know who intervened against
us
the obama biden administration and
california
attorney general kamala harris
they argued against us at the u.s
supreme court
their comrades labeled us spawns of
satan
and slandered us in mainstream media
no matter their abuse we'll keep
fighting for the country and children we
love
just like president trump he's breaking
the union's grip
on our schools that's why unions have
tried to destroy him
since the day he was elected but
president trump isn't afraid to fight
for what's right
he won't back down his courage gives
great teachers
renewed hope he's even proposed
education freedom scholarships
to return control to parents protect
religious liberties
and empower kids to escape dangerous
low-performing schools
the republican platform supports
educational freedom
the democrat party does not
democrats stand with deceptive teachers
unions
who pick on loving teachers and little
kids
president trump stands with america's
families great teachers
and most importantly our children
so america's great teachers let's stand
with president trump
in protection of the kids and country we
love
i am so grateful to speak with you today
my name is tanya weinrice i am from
montana where i live with my husband
my hero a marine and retired police
officer
my husband and i own mountain led
espresso
we are not some multinational
corporation
our success is not measured by
stockholders
but by our neighbors the people we see
at church
and at jiu jitsu school with our son
mountain mud espresso is the american
story
a story not just for entrepreneurs but
for millions of hard
working men and women who are building
their american dream
every day a few months ago like so many
businesses we got the crushing news
a large event we were serving was
cancelled because of the virus
our business was on the brink threatened
to be shut down
from losses that were not our fault
i was scared i thought of our 50
employees
the mountain mud family and when i
thought of their jobs i thought of their
rent being due
their kids and i felt personally
responsible
i'm not too proud to admit that i fell
on my knees and prayed
lord what do i do his words ran clear
keep on working it will be okay
i had faith and let me tell you you have
to have faith when your husband is a
marine
and a police officer who was shot at on
the job
and when you run a business a little
faith goes a long way
faith in jesus and faith in america
but i'm worried we have a generation of
americans who have been told that the
american dream
doesn't exist that's a lie
i know because i live that dream it's
why i feel
so strongly that we need a president who
believes
in the american dream like president
donald trump
now more than ever i am so thankful that
my prayers for help were answered
my company was one of the first to
receive a ppp
loan and praise god it has been a
lifesaver
not only were we able to keep every
single employee but we've been hiring
weekly
ever since i feel for local businesses
across america
who are under assault from shutdowns
from riots
and now facing the terrifying prospect
of joe biden
coming after everything we've built
i am so grateful we have leaders like
president trump
standing up for local businesses like
mine
thank you president trump it is exciting
to be part of the great american
comeback story
i'm congressman matt gates i'm speaking
to you from an auditorium
emptier than joe biden's daily schedule
but we are a nation of full hearts and
clear minds
we see the choice clearly strength or
weakness
energy or confusion success or failure
president trump is the first president
since reagan not to start a new war
biden has foolishly cheerled decades of
war without winning
without end president trump knows we are
strongest when we fight hardest
not in distant deserts but for our
fellow americans
we must fight to save america now or we
may lose her forever
joe biden might not even notice settle
for biden
that's the hashtag promoted by aoc and
the socialists
the woktopians will settle for biden
because they will make him an extra in a
movie
written produced and directed by others
it's a horror film really
they'll disarm you empty the prisons
lock you in your home
and invite ms-13 to live next door and
the police aren't coming when you call
and democrat-run cities they're already
being defunded
disbanded blaming our best and
allowing society's worst that's the
story they write in hollywood
that's if the lights even stay on in
california anymore
a state that cannot keep power running
for its own people
should not send its junior senator to be
vice president
they used to write only in fiction but
nightmares are becoming real
cops killed children shot at the
democrat convention they say
if you vote against trump it will all
stop
appeasement is never a winning strategy
no we won't settle for violence in our
neighborhoods or at our border
we won't settle for decades of bad
decisions by basement dwelling joe biden
we settle a continent we know that the
frontier the horizon
even the stars belong to us donald trump
like all builders
is a visionary that which is built in
the mind is
even more powerful than the brick and
mortar that holds it together
first comes the mind then the making
first comes the
vision then the work washington lincoln
and jefferson are immortal
precisely because of the pull they have
on our imagination
you cannot cancel a culture that loves
its heroes
the dangerous left need america to be
weaker to accomplish their goal of
replacing her
we know that to make america great again
we must first make something
of ourselves that is the meaning of true
strength
my great-grandfather was a railroad man
as a florida man i watch our rockets
routinely send
the brightest beyond the heavens with
our flag and our hope
america is the greatest country that has
ever existed
don't let any celebrity athlete or
politician tell you otherwise
president trump sometimes raises his
voice and a ruckus
he knows that's what it takes to raise
an army of patriots
who love america and will protect her
we must win this election if we cherish
our country as much as we should
for there is no place to run no refuge
for freedom should we fail
america is not just an idea or a
constitution
it is our home we must protect our home
with unbreakable made in america
strength
strength i see every day in president
donald trump
thank you
my name is kim klasik and i'm running
for congress in maryland 7th district
and like shirley chisholm i'm unbought
and unbossed
let me remind you the democrats have
controlled this part of baltimore city
for over 50 years
and they have run this beautiful place
right into the ground
abandoned buildings liquor stores in
every corner drug addicts guns on the
street
that's now the norm in many
neighborhoods you think
maryland taxpayers will be getting a
whole lot since our taxes are out of
control
instead we're paying for decades of
incompetence and corruption
sadly the same cycle of decay exists and
many of america's democrat-run cities
and yet the democrats still assume that
black people will vote for them no
matter how much they let us down and
take us for granted
we're sick of it we're not going to take
it anymore
the days of blindly supporting the
democrats are coming to an end
in baltimore we have the highest number
of black republicans in the entire
country running for office this election
cycle
joe biden believes we can't think for
ourselves that the color of someone's
skin
dictates their political views we're not
buying the lies anymore
you and your party have neglected us for
far too long we want safety in our
neighborhoods
we want to make the most of the federal
opportunity zone i'm standing in right
now
in west baltimore we want higher paying
jobs and more business opportunities
we want lower taxes we want school
choice we want a chance to get ahead not
just get by
that's what president trump promised and
that's what president trump delivered
i want baltimore to be an example to
republicans around the country
that we can compete in our inner cities
if we reach out to the citizens and
deliver real results
president trump is bringing this country
back roaring
he's bringing the american spirit to
life for all americans
so i'm asking you to help president
trump
complete this great american comeback
and then i'm asking you
to help me start this great baltimore
comeback thank you and god bless america
good evening i'm ronna mcdaniel
chairwoman of the republican
national committee and on behalf of
everyone in our party and president
trump
thank you for tuning in as we kick off
this historic
convention as we speak to you tonight we
send our thoughts and prayers to those
facing terrible fires in california
recovering from storms in iowa and
preparing for hurricanes
in louisiana and the gulf coast
democrats started their convention last
week with eva longoria
a famous hollywood actress who played a
housewife on tv well i'm
actually a real housewife and a mom from
michigan
with two wonderful kids in public school
who happens to be
the only only the second woman in 164
years to run the republican party
and unlike joe biden president trump
didn't choose me because i'm a woman
he chose me because i was the best
person
for the job four years ago president
trump started a movement
unlike any other and over the next four
days we will hear from a few of the
millions of hard-working
everyday americans who have benefited
from his leadership
if you watched the dnc last week you
probably noticed
that democrats spent a lot of time
talking about how much they despise our
president
but we heard very little about their
actual
policies policies that would have been
unthinkable
a decade ago policies like banning
fossil fuels
eliminating private health insurance
taxpayer-funded health care for people
who come here
illegally and defunding the police
their argument for joe biden boiled down
to the fact that they think
he's a nice guy well let me tell you
raising taxes on 82 percent of americans
is not nice eliminating 10
million good paying oil and gas jobs is
not
nice policies that force jobs to flee
our country
or allow abortion up until the point of
birth
are not nice the truth is
there's only one person who has
empathized with
everyday americans and actually been
fighting for them over the past four
years
and that is president donald trump
in the nearly four years i've worked on
behalf of president trump
i've seen up close a man who has a deep
love for family
a man who has reverence for the office
of the presidency
a man with an incredible respect for law
enforcement in our military
i've seen private moments where he
comforts americans
in times of pain and sadness
now everyone knows he can be tough
he's tough when he takes on china tough
when he works to fix our unfair trade
deals
tough when he fights to secure our
borders president trump
is always going to be tough when he is
fighting for the american people
because nice guys like joe cared more
about countries like china and iran
than the united states of america
tonight
begins a new chapter in the great
american story
a story that has inspired the world for
generations
and when we re-elect president trump
this november the best is yet to come
this election is the most important in
our lifetime
your vote counts more than ever if you
want to check your voting status
secure your ballot or register to vote
text vote to 88022
earlier today president trump and vice
president pence
came to north carolina to thank our
delegates for unanimously
renominating them to a second term our
official roll call and the business of
our republican convention
was conducted today in charlotte we have
created a short video to symbolize the
excitement for president trump across
all 50 states and territories thank you
for watching
god bless you and god bless the united
states of america
the great state of alabama alaska
american cyborg arizona arkansas
california colorado or connecticut
delaware district of columbia
florida georgia guam hawaii
illinois indiana iowa kansas kentucky
louisiana
maine maryland massachusetts michigan
minnesota mississippi missouri
montana new hampshire new jersey new
mexico new york the north carolina north
dakota the northern mariana islands
ohio oklahoma oregon pennsylvania puerto
rico
rhode island south carolina south dakota
tennessee
united states virgin islands utah
vermont virginia
west virginia wisconsin wyoming we're
excited to nominate
donald j trump and vice president mike
pence
for four more years thank you for all
you've done
to make america great again it is our
privilege to nominate you for four more
years
and we know the best is yet to come
four more years four more years
four more years four more years
four more years
we will make america great again
and ladies and gentlemen of this country
the best is yet to come
i didn't back down from my promises and
i've kept
every single one
this current administration have made
hope possible
we want this nation to continue to
be the beacon of hope for the world how
many people
said they're going to leave america if
donald trump was elected they're all
still here
and they're not going anywhere because
we are in the land of the free
we will never ever sign bad
trade deals america first again
america first america's great usmca
trademark this is a big win for the
united states of america that's a great
trade deal
we are going to lift the restrictions on
the production
of american energy we will create
millions of more jobs hope to me is the
belief
in a better tomorrow and creating a
better future for our children
when i look in the eyes of my
grandchildren i want them to know that
their papa
was not silent we will rescue kids
from failing schools by helping their
parents
send them to a safe school of their
choice
we will completely rebuild our depleted
military the countries that we are
protecting
at a massive cost to us we'll be
asked to pay their fair share
we will take care of our great veterans
like they have never been taken care of
before this guy's safe yeah
thanks to him i'm here
to me he's giving people hope
what he's doing for the poor people what
he's doing for
everybody we are going to appoint
justices of the united states supreme
court
who will uphold our laws and our
constitution by supporting law
enforcement is so important for keeping
america great
as long as i'm president i will never
defund your police that i promise you
it's time to deliver a victory
for the american people we are going to
start
winning again
it's called promises made promises
my name is amy ford i've been a
registered nurse for 17 years
i'm from the small town of williamson
west virginia where i've lived my entire
life
the daughter of a nurse and a coal miner
even though i was the youngest of four
children i was always somewhat of a
caretaker
it came natural for me so it felt right
to follow in my mother's footsteps and
become a nurse
and this march when covert 19 sent our
country into crisis
i knew i had to help any way that i
could i deployed to new york in april
and then to san antonio texas working as
a covered relief nurse
in both states as i contended with the
challenges of treating our patients
who had their worlds turned upside down
i noticed a positive change in our
health care system
president trump recognized the threat
this virus presented for all americans
early on
and made rapid policy changes and
as a result telehealth services are now
accessible
to more than 71 million americans
including
35 million children prior to coving
telehealth was not covered or reimbursed
under medicare medicaid or chip
this left our most vulnerable
populations with no other choice
but to have an in-person office visit
with their physicians
increasing their risk of exposure to
covenanting exponentially
the expansion of telehealth services has
also resulted in the integration of
video visits
between patients and their families
allowing loved ones
to have contact and visualization as
well as a better understanding of care
telehealth has been essential during
this pandemic
i don't want the media taking my
personal story and twisting it
so let me be clear as a healthcare
professional
i can tell you without hesitation donald
trump's
quick action and leadership saved
thousands of lives
during covenanting and the benefits of
that response extend far beyond
coronavirus
telehealth will continue to aid many
that are just unable to find
transportation
or way to the doctor for regular
checkups
this is especially true in rural america
i live in a town of about 2 000 people
we do not have buses
trains trolleys or ubers available to us
in addition the unavailability of
services can also hinder treatment for
many
so increased access to telehealth for
millions of americans
has truly been life-saving and we have
president trump to thank
from the very beginning democrats the
media
and the world health organization got
coronavirus wrong
the world health organization said
authorities have found
no clear evidence of human to human
transmission
overall most people should not be
terribly concerned about it everything
is
fine here we do want to say to people
come to chinatown
here we are come join us we don't even
think
it's going to be as bad as it was in
other countries go about your lives go
about your business
one leader took decisive action to save
lives
president donald trump banning travel
from china
and coronavirus epicenters biden charged
xenophobia
but president trump was right signing
the cares act providing
immediate relief to american families
workers and
businesses declaring a national
emergency tapping into 42 billion
in existing emergency funding quickly
getting crucial personal protective
equipment to the states
signing the family's first coronavirus
response act ensuring that american
families
and businesses impacted by the virus
receive the strong support
they need launching operation wharf
speed
to fast track a vaccine in record time
he said everything that i could have
hoped for promise made
promise kept he is ready willing and
able to help
he has been responsive he's done a lot
of good things
what the federal government did was a
phenomenal accomplishment
in our hour of need and you all
literally are helping us in a big way
we were at the edge and this is life or
death stuff and we're forever thankful
for that
soon we will emerge safer stronger
and greater than ever
i am dr g e golly an oral and
maxillofacial surgeon
and chancellor of a large academic
medical and research center in louisiana
i feel uniquely positioned to share how
president trump's
decisive leadership led to a rapid and
efficient response to the coronavirus
pandemic
i know this as a health professional and
as someone who has recovered from covet
himself
the kovit 19 pandemic exploded into our
great nation
with an intensity unparalleled in
history
but our medical investigation and drug
development systems
were not designed for a pandemic the
devastating effects of the coronavirus
demanded immediate changes
at the regulatory level a prompt
response
led by president trump cleared away the
red tape that usually makes drug
approvals a long and drawn out process
by harnessing the resources the federal
government in the private sector
president trump's operation warp speed
is accelerating the testing
supply development and distribution of
therapeutics
diagnostics and very shortly effective
vaccines to counter
covid19 let me give you three clear
examples
of how president trump's leadership
removed regulatory barriers
so covid patients could have faster
access to effective therapies and
diagnostics
first on february 26th two
phase three clinical trials studying rim
desevere
were initiated just two months later
the fda approved room desevere for
emergency use to treat kovid 19.
normally this is a three to five year
process
the amazing speed with which this
happened in a safe
but efficient manner is unheard of
second the fda granted expanded access
to covid19 convalescent plasma
within 24 hours of this approval we were
administering
convalescent plasma and room desevere to
a critically ill patient
a former army ranger and physician
had not been for the rapid deployment of
these medicines
this patient who is my colleague and
friend
would have surely died and third
at the end of july i developed a fever
and cough
i reached out to our testing team and
received one
of the abbott rapid tests yet another
tool quickly approved by this
administration
within 15 minutes my test came back
positive
and within four hours i was receiving my
room desevere doses
followed by an infusion of convalescent
plasma as a physician
i've seen firsthand how these
breakthroughs have saved countless lives
as a patient i've benefited from the
expedited therapies made possible by the
swift action of this administration
president trump truly moved mounts to
save lives and he deserves credit
thank you president trump for providing
timely access
to critical diagnostics and therapeutics
during this pandemic
thank you mr president for your strong
leadership in these challenging times
when the china virus invaded our country
we launched the greatest mobilization of
american society since world war ii
patriots of every race color and creed
rallied together to defeat the invisible
enemy
and save the lives of their fellow
citizens today our hearts
overflow with appreciation for the
incredible front-line workers
who risked their own health and safety
to keep
america strong and safe
when crisis came millions of everyday
americans rose to the challenge
in their actions we see true greatness
of the american character
we always find a way to victory
history will remember and celebrate the
heroes of 2020
for as long as our great american flag
waves over the land that we love
to every frontline worker i offer the
salute of a nation that is forever in
your debt
thank you god bless you and god bless
america
these are my friends these are the
incredible workers that helped us so
much with the kovid
we can call it many different things
from china virus i don't want to go
through all the names because some
people may get insulted but that's the
way it is
these are great great people doctors
nurses
a fireman a policeman we want to thank
you all you've been
incredible and we want to thank you and
all of the millions of people that you
represent
thank you all very much great job thank
you thank you
thank you all very much so tell me a
little about your stories how about
we'll start with you
i'm a postal worker delivered to the
senior community during
coca-19 good and we're taking good care
of our postal workers
that i can tell you believe me we're not
getting rid of our postal workers you
know they'd like to
sort of put that out there if anyone
does it's the democrats not the
republicans
i want to thank you very much and thank
everybody in that whole beautiful post
office system we appreciate it
how about you i'm a trucker good own a
small business in ohio
great uh holland steel mostly um
you know some of our customers actually
made hospital beds with uh
material that's fantastic well
congratulations i love the truckers you
know they're on my side
thank you i think all of them frankly i
think pretty much all of them
how about you i'm a custodian at the
post office as well
what do you do exactly clean up
everybody's mess and everybody's germs
and
all that can i say that that world that
profession will never be out of business
you know that right
thank you very much for being here thank
you thank you and how about you um
i'm a registered nurse president trump i
work at a new jersey hospital it's
called virtual
rolling barrel hospital right um i also
represent an organization of
professional nurses
it's called the national association of
catholic nurses very good but i want to
tell you sir as a nursing supervisor
i am so in awe of your leadership
honestly
i know many people have said often
interesting things but
it takes a true leader to be able to
ignore all that stuff and do what is
right
and not be offended by all the words
being said and
you really do show that positive spirit
to us and as nurses i appreciate that
but just as an individual
i'm grateful for that well i'm for the
nurses i'm for the doctors i'm for
everybody we just have to make this
china virus go away and it's happening
please go ahead
i'm also a nurse i represent genesis
healthcare which is a skill nursing
facility
company um i want to thank you and your
administration for all the supplies and
support and funding that you've given
the skilled nursing units
um without that we couldn't
do as well as we have done i spent some
time in new jersey i live in west
virginia went to new jersey and did some
work there
and we finally started to see things
change and turn around i appreciate what
you said because
we have delivered billions of dollars of
equipment that governors were supposed
to give and in many cases
they didn't get so the federal
government had to help them
and all of the people that did this
incredible work they never got credit
for it
but you understand where it came from
thank you very much thank you both
it's really nice please go ahead i'm a
police officer in englewood colorado
and i contracted covid in late march
and recovered that means we don't have
to be afraid of you at all
once you're recovered you know we have
the whole thing with plasma happening
that means your blood is very valuable
you know that right
thank you very much great please i'm a
detention deputy the kern county
sheriff's department out in california
and uh i also contracted coven um
into march and recovered from that also
how long was your
problem um i was sick about 10 days
really bad
i got everything besides the cough um
but recovered i was off work for a month
and a half
and i work in our local county jails did
they do anything specifically to help
you recover
they gave me zpax medication cough syrup
okay
and i won't even ask you about the
hydroxychloroquine because
it's a shame what they've done to that
one but but i took it i took the z pack
also
and zinc i want to thank you all very
much
it's an honor to have you in the white
house you're fantastic people and the
people you represent you represent
an incredible group of people and we
love you all
thank you very much thank you very much
appreciate it
good evening i'm congressman jim jordan
representing the fourth district of ohio
the republican party is the pro-america
party president trump is the pro-america
candidate
this election is about who can preserve
the values principles
and institutions that make america great
don't believe me
look at what's happening in american
cities cities all run by democrats
crime violence and mob rule democrats
refuse to denounce the mob
and their response to the chaos defund
the police
defund border patrol and defund our
military
and while they're doing all this they're
also trying to take away your guns
look at the positions they've taken in
the past few months democrats won't let
you go to church
but they'll let you protest democrats
won't let you go to work
but they'll let you riot the democrats
won't let you go to school
but they'll let you go loot president
trump has fought against each of their
crazy ideas
he's taken on the swamp all of the swamp
the democrats
the press and the never trumpers and
when you take on the swamp
the swamp fights back they tried the
russia hoax
the mueller investigation and the fake
impeachment
but in spite of this unbelievable
opposition this president has done what
he said he would do
taxes cut regulations reduced economy
growing
lowest unemployment 50 years out of the
iran deal embassy in jerusalem hostages
home from north korea
a new usmca agreement and of course he's
building the wall
and rebuilding our economy as we speak
i love the president's intensity and his
willingness to fight every day in
washington for
our families but what i also appreciate
about the president
is something most americans never get to
see how much he truly cares about people
our family has seen it two years ago our
nephew eli was killed in a car accident
he lived a mile up the road from us grew
up wrestling and training with our boys
was a high school state champion varsity
athlete for the university of wisconsin
it's so saturday morning three days
after the accident
i walked to the car to head up to eli's
parents home when the president called
we talked about a few issues and then he
asked how the family was doing
i said they're doing okay mr president
but it's tough
the president said yeah losing a loved
one is always difficult
and it's really tough when they're so
young i then said mr president i'm
actually walking into their house right
now
obviously they don't know that i'm
talking to you but if you'd be willing
to say hello to eli's dad
you'd make a terrible day a little less
terrible what's his name the president
asked
i walked through the door and said todd
the president wants to talk to you
for the next five minutes family and
friends sat in complete silence
as the president of the united states
took time to talk to a dad who was
hurting
that's the president i've gotten to know
the last four years
the president who shared private moments
like this with soldiers
victims of violent crime and people
who've had businesses
destroyed by the mob that's the
individual who's made america great
again
and who knows america's best days are
still in front of us
and that's why i'm busting my tail to
help him get reelected
i'm asking you to do the same thank you
and god bless our country
i'm not an actor a singer or a
politician
i'm hershel walker most of you know me
as a football player
but i'm also a father a man of faith
and a very good judge of character i've
known donald trump for 37 years
and i don't mean just casual ranting to
him from time to time
i'm talking about a deep personal
friendship
i watched him as an owner of a
professional football team
right after he bought the team he set
out to learn
he learned about the history of the team
the players the coaches
every detail then he used what he
learned to make the team better
i watched him in the board room he can
be in the middle of a big meeting
but if one of the kids was on the phone
he dropped everything to take the call
he taught me that the family should be
your top priority
i watch him treat janitors security
guards and waiters
the same way we treated vip he made them
feel special
because he knew they were he understands
that they are the people who make this
country run
they clean they cook they build they
drive
they deliver he told me herschel
make an effort to get to know people
remember their names
that stuck with me one time i planned to
take his kids to disney world with my
family
at the last minute donald said he'd like
to join us
so there he was in a business suit on uh
it's a small world ride that was
something to see
it just shows you what a care and loving
father he is
it hurt my soul to hear the terrible
names that people call donald
the worst one is racist i take it as a
personal insult that people would think
i've had a 37-year friendship with the
races
people who think that don't know what
they're talking about
growing up in the deep south i've seen
racism up close
i know what it is and it isn't donald
trump
just because someone loves and respects
the flag our national anthem in our
country
doesn't mean they don't care about
social justice i care about all those
things
so does donald trump he shows how much
he cares about social justice in the
black community through his actions
and his actions speaks louder than
stickers or slogans on a jersey
he keeps right on fighting to improve
the lives of black americans
and all americans he work night and day
he never stops he leaves nothing on the
field
some people don't like his style the way
he knocks down obstacles that get in the
way of his goals
people on an opposing team that like
when i ran over them either
but that's how you get the job done i
pray every night that god gives him more
time
give him four more years he has
accomplished so much
almost all by himself on a constant
attack
but there's still more work to be done
if you love america and want to make it
better
donald trump is your president he's my
president
and i'm blessed to call him friend
good evening i'm natalie harp a formerly
forgotten american
from california in the classic jimmy
stewart film it's a wonderful life
george bailey is given a great gift the
chance to see
what the world would be like without him
tonight mr president
we'd like to give you that same gift
because without you
we'd all be living in pottersville sold
out to a crooked mister
or i should say a crooked mrs potter
with no hope of escape except death
itself i should know
because i wouldn't be alive today if it
wasn't for you
about five years ago i was the victim of
a notoriously deadly medical heir
i survived but only to be diagnosed with
a rare
and terminal bone cancer you know the
democrats love to talk about health care
being a human right
but a right to what well i'll tell you
to them it's a right to marijuana
opioids
and the right to die with dignity a
politically correct way of saying
assisted suicide
i was told i was a burden to my family
and to my country
and that by choosing to die early i'd
actually be saving the lives of others
by preserving resources for them rather
than wasting that
cause like myself and when i failed the
chemotherapies that were on the market
no one wanted me in their clinical
trials i'd make them look bad
they didn't give me the right to try
experimental treatments mr president
you did and without you i'd have died
waiting for them to be approved
now with the coronavirus everyone knows
what that feels like to be waiting
for a cure but we've only been waiting a
few months just imagine what 2020 would
have looked like
fighting for your life without donald
trump fighting for it too
in january there would have been no
china travel ban
millions would have died millions more
would have been infected
for there be no record levels of testing
no right to try
treatments no fast track for a vaccine
nor
operation warp speed ready to deliver it
and without donald trump
as our patient advocate for the past
four years well
the opioid epidemic would have stolen
even more lives from even more families
kidney patients would have no future
except
dying on wait lists for there be known
initiative to increase donations
there'd still be no accountability at
the va and our brave veterans
would still be suffering long wait times
with no choice
nor access to faster care insulin and
other drug prices would have continued
to rise
while a record number of generic drugs
would still be stuck in the pipeline
there'd be no price transparency we
wouldn't have health plans up to 60
percent cheaper than obamacare
and we'd still be stuck with that
infamous individual mandate
and god forbid what the next four years
would look like
for in joe biden's america china would
control our drug production
we'd be one step closer to
government-run health care
we wouldn't just be unable to keep our
doctors we'd be lucky if we could see
any doctor
and even then some of us would be denied
care
for in socialized medicine you don't
beat the odds you become the odds
and i would lose my right to try
just really hard that terminally ill
british baby
whose government-run health care system
decided it was
too expensive and too cruel to keep
him alive you see mr president
you've done so much more than your
promises made and promises kept
for numbers only tell part of the story
we are the rest of it facts with faces
of americans who would still be
forgotten if you
and our favorite first lady hadn't given
up your own wonderful life
so we could have the chance at one
george bailey's father was right
all you can take with you is that what
you've given away
and mr president that makes you the
richest man in the world
for you have used your strength to make
america strong
again sacrifice the life you built
to make america proud again and you
risked everything to make america safe
again
it's a wonderful life you made america
great
again and on november 3rd we are going
to keep
america great
hello america my name is vernon jones
and i'm a state representative
from the great state of georgia as you
can see
i'm a man of color and i'm a lifelong
democrat too
you may be wondering why is a lifelong
democrat speaking
at the republican national convention
and that's a fair
question and here's your answer
the democratic party does not want black
people
to leave their mental plantation we've
been forced
to be there for decades and generations
but i have news for joe biden we are
free we are free people with free minds
and i'm part of a large and growing
segment of the black community
who are independent thinkers and we
believe that donald trump
is the president that america needs to
lead us forward
this is no time for sleeping in the
basement joe biden has had
47 years to produce results
but he's been all talk and no action
just like so many of the democrats
who've been making promises
to the black voters for decades we've
been their captive audience
when president trump sought to earn the
black vote the democratic party leaders
went crazy
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer literally
started wearing kente cloths around
the us capitol as if
pandering were enough to keep us
satisfied
let me tell you why i'm supporting our
president
i grew up in the south in laurel hill
north carolina
scotland county the green pond community
to be exact
my parents robin and roofer jones built
with their own hands
a four-room cinderblock home with no
indoor plumbing
they had very limited education but they
instilled in us a strong work ethic
that drove me from those tobacco fields
of north carolina
to those hallowed halls of the georgia
general assembly
my parents taught me if i believed in
god
worked hard and treated every person
fairly
there was no limit to what we could
achieve
i attended north carolina central
university
in historical black college for
generations
hbcus have been the incubators that
develop black scholars
in math and science and religion
engineering
and politics they have been imported
springboards
for the black success but democrats
haven't treated them that way
when president trump took office he
changed everything
he delivered historic funding to hbcus
and he guaranteed it for 10 years
something that has never happened
in the history of this country that gave
our hbcu's stability
the chance to grow and produce the next
generation of black leaders
that's right donald trump did that
he's also supported school choice to
ensure that
no child no matter their race or zip
code
is left behind every child should have
access to a quality education
but education is just the beginning the
president also built the most inclusive
economy ever
with record low unemployment for african
americans
and record high participation in the
workforce
he put opportunity zones in the trump
tax bill
that would drive investment into our
communities for decades to come
he put the interest of american workers
and especially
black workers first that's right
donald trump did that
he delivered historic criminal justice
reform
he ended once and for all the policy of
incarceration
of black people which has decimated our
communities
caused by no other than joe biden
democrats wouldn't do it obama
didn't want to do it and joe biden and
kamala harris definitely wouldn't do it
but donald trump did it he's also
working
every day to make our community safer as
a former
executive of dekalb county georgia
i directed one of the largest public
safety departments in the southeast
i've seen tragic shootings on both sides
officers killing citizens and citizens
killing
officers in the line of duty
police officers are fellow citizens they
live in our country
they have families too they live in our
communities
unfortunately democrats have turned
their backs
on our brave police officers they call
it defunding
and it's a danger to our cities our
neighborhoods
and our children isn't it ironic
that democrat politicians have personal
security
to protect them so why don't they forego
their security and replace them with
social workers
especially since that's what they want
for you and me
our police need more funding not less
for frequent psychological examinations
for non-lethal remote
restraint technology and for more
de-escalation
and use of force training these are the
common sense solutions
that president trump supports true
sincere police reform that's right
donald trump did that too education
jobs safety security
on issue after issue and in just
a single term he destroyed these
negative forces that have victimized
the black community for decades
he gave us the opportunity to rise
now you know when i made the public
announcement of my support for president
trump
all hell broke loose i was threatened
called an embarrassment and asked to
resign by my own party
unfortunately that's consistent
with the democratic party and how they
view
independent thinking black men
and women but i'm here to tell you
that black voices are becoming more woke
and louder than ever
the democratic party has become infected
with a pandemic
of intolerance bigotry
socialism anti-law enforcement bias
and a dangerous tolerance for people who
attack
others destroy their property and
terrorize our own
communities that's what this election is
all about
and that's why right now more than ever
more than ever before america needs
donald trump in the oval office for
another four years
god bless you and vote donald j trump
thank you
in 2018 a gunman walked into marjory
stoneman douglas high school in parkland
florida
and changed my life forever my name is
andrew pollock
his name isn't worth saying
one of the seniors walking in the
hallways that day was my beautiful
daughter
meadow she was just months away from
graduating and beginning a new life
we were so proud of the woman she had
become
but in the hallway on that third floor
the gunman saw meadow
and shot her down the hallway hitting
her four times
after she was shot and on the floor she
crawled over to another student
a freshman girl to protect her
she draped her body over her and then
the scumbag gunman
shot my daughter at point blank range
five more times
killing meadow and the girl she was
shielding
she had a whole life ahead of her and in
that life
she could have done anything and been
anything
so many moments that i waited so long
for were taken from me
i didn't get to drop her off at college
i didn't get to walk it down the aisle
but every moment was taken from her and
for what
i never wanted this to become a
political spectacle but it did
i never wanted to meet the president
like this but i did
i was invited to the white house the
truth is i
just buried my daughter that week i
really wasn't interested in public
events like a tour or a photo
op i was interested in answers and
solutions
so if the president wanted to meet me
personally i said i'd go
they said of course that was his plan
at the white house my family and i sat
with the president in the oval office
and told him about meadow
i told him what we knew i told him that
his administration
needed to take a closer look at what
went wrong and why
and i got to see who president trump
really is
he's a good man and a great listener and
he cuts through the bs
then the president did what he said he
would do he took action
he formed the school safety commission
that issued dozens of recommendations to
make schools safer
but i'll bet you never heard about that
instead
the media turned my daughter's murder
went to a coordinated attack on
president trump
republicans and our second amendment
in fact when president trump asked me
and other parents of children
that were murdered in school shootings
to join him as he announced the
commission's findings
the media's first question wasn't about
protecting kids
shockingly they asked about the
government shutdown
president trump turned to me appalled
and said andy
can you believe these people we're
trying to talk about school safety
and this is what they do but i could
believe it
after my daughter's murder the media
didn't seem interested in the facts
so i found them myself i learned that
gun control laws didn't fail my daughter
people did the gunman had threatened to
kill his classmates before
he had threatened to rape them he had
threatened to shoot up to school
every red flag you can imagine but the
school didn't just miss these red flags
they knowingly ignored them
far left democrats in our school
district made this shooting possible
because they implemented something they
called restorative justice
this policy which really just blames
teachers for students failures
puts kids and teachers at risk and makes
shootings more likely
but it was billed as a pioneering
approach to discipline and safety
i was just fine with the old approach to
discipline and safety
it was called discipline and safety but
the obama biden administration took
parkland's bad policies
and forced them into schools across
america
when president trump rescinded obama's
guidance on restorative justice policies
he put an end to that and that meant the
world to me
it's hard to tell how much mr biden
understands about what happened at
parkland
mr biden has campaigned on bringing back
restorative justice
as part of as part of his unity platform
with bernie sanders and has pledged to
implement in school districts across
america
but he doesn't even seem to know when
the shooting happened
he said that he was vice president when
it happened but he wasn't
mr biden may not know when my daughter
was murdered but i do
february 14 2018
mr biden may not know that these
policies make shootings more likely but
i do
mr biden may not know who was vice
president that day but i do
it wasn't joe biden it was mike pence
thank god and i know who the president
was too
it wasn't barack obama it was president
donald j
trump and he took action
i truly believe the safety of our kids
depends on whether this man is
re-elected
i hope you'll join me in helping to make
that happen
mr president myself and millions of
americans appreciate you and love you
god bless america and god bless our
president donald j
trump thank you
a curfew effect for the city of saint
louis protests in st louis turned
violent
mark mcclowsky says he and his family
have been threatened with violence
under missouri law you have a right to
defend your home and the lives of your
family
a search warrant has been executed at
the home of mark and patricia mccleskey
the husband and wife attorneys charged
with pointing guns at protesters
they were simply trying to protect their
home good evening america
we are mark and patty mccloskey we're
speaking to you tonight from st
louis missouri where just weeks ago you
may have seen us
defending our home as a mob of
protesters descended on our neighborhood
america is such a great country that not
only do you have the right to own a gun
and use it to defend yourself but
thousands
of americans will offer you free advice
on how to use it
at least that's what we experienced what
you saw happen to us
could just as easily happen to any of
you who are watching from quiet
neighborhoods
around our country and that's what we
want to speak to you
about tonight that's exactly right
whether it's the defunding of police
ending cash bail so criminals can be
released
back out on the streets the same day to
riot again
or encouraging anarchy and chaos on our
streets
it seems as if the democrats no longer
view the government's job
as protecting honest citizens from
criminals
but rather protecting criminals from
honest citizens
not a single person in the out of
control mob you saw our house
was charged with a crime but you know
who was
we were they've actually charged us with
felonies
for daring to defend our home
on top of that consider this the marxist
liberal activist leading the mob to our
neighborhood
stood outside our home with a ball horn
screaming
you can't stop the revolution just weeks
later
that same marxist activist won the
democrat nomination
to hold a seat in the u.s house of
representatives
in the city of st louis that's the same
as winning the general election
that marxist revolutionary is now going
to be
the congresswoman from the first
district of missouri
these radicals are not content with
marching in the streets
they want to walk the halls of congress
they want to take over
they want power this is joe biden's
party
these are the people who will be in
charge of your future and the future of
your children
they're not satisfied with spreading the
chaos and violence
into our communities they want to
abolish the suburbs altogether
by ending single-family home zoning this
forestry zoning would bring crime
lawlessness and low-quality apartments
into now thriving suburban neighborhoods
president trump smartly ended this
government overreach
but joe biden wants to bring it back
these are the policies that are coming
to a neighborhood near you
so make no mistake no matter where you
live
your family will not be safe in the
radical democrats
america at this moment in history
if you stand up for yourself and for the
values our country was founded on
the mob spurred on by their allies in
the media
will try to destroy you you've seen us
on your tv
screens and twitter feeds you know that
we're not the kind of people who back
down
thankfully neither is donald trump
president trump will defend the
god-given right
of every american to protect their homes
and their families but more than that
trump's vision for america
is a country where you have an
opportunity to work hard
and build the life you dream of with a
job you love
with your children being educated in
great schools
in a community where your family can
play in the backyard without fear
worship in a church without shame and
express
your beliefs without retribution
trump brought us the greatest economy
our country had ever seen
the democrats have brought us nothing
but destruction
when we don't have basic safety and
security in our communities
we'll never be free to build a brighter
future for ourselves
for our children or for our country
that's what's at stake in this election
and that's why we must re-elect donald
trump
god bless you god bless the president
and god
bless the united states
good evening america i'm kimberly
guilfoyle
i speak to you tonight as a mother a
former prosecutor
a latina and a proud american
and yes a proud supporter of president
donald
j trump why because he is the
president who delivers for america
he built the greatest economy the world
has ever known
for the strivers the working class and
middle class
as commander-in-chief he always puts
america first
president trump is the law and order
president
now presidential leadership is not
guaranteed
it is a choice biden harris and the rest
of the socialists will fundamentally
change this nation they want open
borders
closed schools dangerous amnesty and
will
selfishly send your jobs back to china
while they get rich
they will defund dismantle and destroy
america's law
enforcement when you are in trouble
and need police don't count
on the democrats as a first generation
american
i know how dangerous their socialist
agenda is
my mother mercedes was a special
education teacher from aguadilla puerto
rico
my father also an immigrant came to this
nation in pursuit of the american dream
now i consider it my duty to fight to
protect
that dream rioters must not be allowed
to destroy our cities
human sex drug traffickers should not be
allowed to cross our border
the same socialist policies which
destroyed
places like cuba and venezuela
must not take root in our cities
and our schools if you want to see the
socialist
biden harris future for our country
just take a look at california
it is a place of immense wealth
immeasurable innovation
an immaculate environment and the
democrats turned it into a land of
discarded heroin needles in parks
riots and streets and blackouts in homes
in president trump's america we
light things up we don't dim them down
we build things up we don't burn them
down
we kneel in prayer and we stand
for our flag
this election is a battle for the soul
of america
your choice is clear
do you support the cancel culture
the cosmopolitan elites of nancy pelosi
chuck schumer and joe biden
who blame america first do
you think america is to blame
or do you believe in american greatness
believe in yourself
in president trump in individual and
personal responsibility
they want to destroy this country
and everything that we have fought for
and hold dear
they want to steal your liberty your
freedom
they want to control what you see and
think and believe so that they can
control
how you live
they want to enslave you to the weak
dependent
liberal victim ideology to the point
that you will not
recognize this country or yourself
from the beginning when president trump
spoke about making
america great again he was speaking
about that shining city on a hill
and restoring the beacon of light that
once shined
so bright his promise was to put
america first and he has
when president trump cut middle-class
taxes
putting tens of thousands of dollars
back in the pockets of working-class
americans
that beacon began to flicker once again
when president trump commanded the
defeat of isis
took out al-baghdadi and solemani and
paved the way
for peace in the middle east that beacon
started to glow when he negotiated
historic trade deals with canada
mexico japan and china bringing back
thousands of manufacturing jobs to
america
that beacon shined bright once again for
the world to see
america it's all on the line
president trump believes in you he
emancipates and lifts you
up to live your american dream
you are capable you are qualified you
are
powerful and you have the ability to
choose your life
and determine your destiny
don't let the democrats take you for
granted don't let them step on you
don't let them destroy your families
your lives and your future
don't let them kill future generations
because they told you and brainwash you
and fed you lies that you weren't good
enough
like my parents you can achieve your
american dream
you can be that shining example to the
world
manifest and be the change in this
country that you dream
that you hope that you believe in
stand for an american president who is
fearless
who believes in you and who loves this
country and will fight for her president
trump is the
leader who will rebuild the promise of
america
and ensure that every citizen can
realize their
american dream ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
i'm congressman steve scalise we're
facing some tough challenges in america
this isn't the first time we've been
here i've worked closely with donald
trump over the last few years
and if there's one constant theme to how
he approaches problems
it's how much he cares about the
hard-working people that washington left
behind
i've seen this firsthand after i was
shot on a baseball field by a leftist
gunman
first responders rushed me to a hospital
where i battled for my life
that same night donald trump came to the
hospital
along with first lady melania trump they
consoled my wife jennifer
they were there for my family in my
darkest hours
donald trump would call to check on me
throughout the following weeks just to
see how i was doing
that's the kind of person he is that's
the side of donald trump that the media
will never show you
look there's a lot at stake this is an
election between a party that wants to
burn down the foundations of our country
to the ground
and a party that wants to rebuild and
protect our great nation
the left wants to defund the police this
is personal to me
i wouldn't be here without the bravery
and heroism of the men and women in law
enforcement who saved my life
president trump stands with those brave
men and women
joe biden has embraced the left's insane
mission to defund them
there won't be an america to leave to
our children and grandchildren
without those brave law enforcement
officers and first responders
joe biden's made a career in washington
for 47 years
promising things he's never delivered in
just three short years
president trump has delivered huge wins
for american families
while joe biden made hollow promises
when he chaired the senate judiciary
committee
donald trump took action and delivered
criminal justice reform
joe biden claims to care about the
working man but
millions of good manufacturing jobs were
shipped overseas during the obama-biden
years
to countries like china donald trump
brought those jobs back
i've seen how deeply president trump
cares about rebuilding our evaporating
middle class
president trump pledged to give the
forgotten men and women of america a
real shot at the american dream
and again he delivered the lowest
unemployment rate in over 50 years
women creating small businesses at
record pace
wages rising the fastest by the way for
lowest income levels
what can joe biden say to that what has
joe biden done in his 47 years in
washington
that can compare to that president trump
has delivered for the hard-working
people of this great nation
it's going to take that kind of bold
leadership to get us out of this covid
crisis
after president trump saved lives by
shutting down flights from
china and europe he's now focusing the
full weight of the government
on a revolutionary plan to cure this
virus by cutting red tape
and empowering scientists to create a
vaccine
this is visionary leadership and action
at a time when we can't afford another
47 years of hollow promises
america's been through tough times
before who better to lead us out of
these times
than the president who already built the
strongest economy our country has ever
seen
donald trump did it before donald trump
will deliver for us
again god bless you and god bless these
united states of america
i'm sean parnell and it is an honor to
be here
in 2006 the army sent me to afghanistan
as a young platoon leader
placed in command of americans from
every corner of our planet
our platoon reflected the diversity of
our nation
every race creed and religion despite
those differences we were bound together
as brothers from the same american
family
on june 10 2006 our platoon was attacked
just after
dawn outnumbered 10 to 1 we endured
mortar and machine gun fire as
hundreds of taliban charged us from
three sides
we had 24 men that day wave
after wave of taliban advanced up the
hill i was wounded three times in the
fighting
nearly all of my platoon is wounded
within the first minute
but the enemy kept coming we fought to
our last rounds of ammunition
and when it was over we held the hill
in the face of death i saw ordinary
americans become heroes
in our darkest hour when our survival
depended
on each other my men and i learned an
important lesson
we all bleed red our differences did not
define us
united we were unbeatable after 485 days
of combat i came home
eager to enjoy the freedoms i risked my
life to defend
but i watched with alarm as the party of
my grandfather
a lifelong union democrat turned against
the very people it professed to
represent
i watched as joe biden spit venom at an
auto worker who dared to question joe's
intent to dismantle the second amendment
and take your guns where democrats once
stood for hard-working
law-abiding americans who displayed our
flag with pride
this new democrat party considers these
people uneducated racists
clinging to guns and bibles the party of
harry truman
became the party of hedge fund managers
hollywood celebrities
tech moguls and university professors
all bloated with contempt for middle
america
i look across the aisle and i do not see
a party
that wants you to pursue your dreams i
see a democrat party that wants to
dictate what those dreams
are i don't see a party that wants you
to be free
i see a party that wants to chain you to
conformity and will destroy
anyone they deem a heretic i swore an
oath to defend my country and its
constitution
president trump has sworn to do the same
that's why he's advanced
freedom despite savage political attacks
to overcome the agenda
of the radical left president trump has
unleashed the economic might of this
nation
like no other president in our history
he triggered the rising tide of working
families
brought us energy independence reclaimed
jobs from overseas that you know
democrats said would never return
he has fiercely defended the besieged
first and second amendments
that is just a start with four more
years
imagine what we can achieve by simply
working
with our president i believe in our
president's vision for the future
i stand here tonight calling on all
americans to join us
it doesn't matter what you look like who
you love how you worship your gender or
your job
if you're a traditional democrat who's
become disillusioned with how radical
your party has become
then stand with us you are most welcome
america needs all her patriots to rush
to her defense
my fellow americans i promise you this
in our tent you are
free free to speak the truth
choose your journey define your life you
have the power to go as far as you aim
then aim higher and keep going because
that is what americans do
we are idealists and dreamers lovers of
adventure we're rugged and independent
we don't make excuses we make the
impossible
a reality think about it in a century
we went from ground-bound dreamers
gazing to the stars
to doers who created the means to reach
them
this is not the time to stand on the
sidelines if you love our country as we
do as
our president does join the chorus of
patriot voices that will preserve this
exceptional union
mr president lead the way
millions in our american family believe
in this path to destiny
guide us to that horizon thank you
and may god bless the united states of
america
we come together to imagine a future
determined by the shining light of our
hopes and values and faith
a country where we are judged by our
character with dignity and respect for
all
the belief that all are created equal
that lives matter
irrespective of race creed or color
committed to excelling beyond our dreams
four years ago we faced an historic
crossroad
career politicians promising change
every election
but delivering emptiness
we chose a different path a man who is
not a politician
a man who cares a man who works
tirelessly
for you
still politicians spawn their deceptions
and obstructed progress
fanning the flames of lawlessness
we all know that it is easy to criticize
it takes a true leader
to solve problems covert 19
while others criticize without solutions
president trump's swift action saved
lives
and as leading democrats want to keep
businesses closed down
our president is leading the way for a
full economic recovery
we are america we as americans work
together to overcome challenges
and write our own stories america
land of promise land of opportunity
land of heroes land of greatness
i thought i had been forgotten
i nearly gave up hope
i was so afraid
i believed i would die here
american hostages forgotten
and wasting away in far-off prisons
wrongfully detained by foreign
governments
americans were beaten abused starved
and left for dead until president
donald trump stepped in the three
american hostages
finally back on u.s soil after being
held captive in north korea we're
following some breaking news in turkey
where an american pastor andrew brunson
has been released an american jailed in
egypt is back in the u.s this morning
after an
intervention by the trump administration
a tough and skilled negotiator
president trump successfully won the
release of detainees and prisoners
among the most of any president in
american history
while families waited in despair for
news of their loved ones
president trump provided a new spark of
hope
by bringing our hostages home we have
danny burch back home where he should be
he was in
yemen in a very horrible situation
yesterday the united states government
secured the release of caitlyn coleman
joshua boyle and their three children
today we are
bringing home another american citizen
we just had news that turkey
released a prisoner that we were trying
to get
to the united states under this
administration
america has not and will not turn its
back on our people
president trump will bring
them home
diplomacy negotiation skills
perseverance
faith the ingredients of hope when there
is no hope
no american should ever be left behind
priority
freeing american hostages
we have six incredible people who were
held hostage by various countries
and i'm very pleased to let everybody
know that we brought back
over 50 hostages from 22 different
countries
we worked very hard on it ambassador
o'brien and others
and i will tell you we uh we're very
proud of the job we did but
i'd like to ask maybe pastor brunson to
say a few words so we can go through and
just give us a little history of what
happened and how is life treating you
i was held in turkey for two years and
you took unprecedented steps actually to
secure my release and your
administration really fought for me
and i don't i think if you hadn't done
that i may still be in turkey
because i'm very great 28 years right
they had you there for
they had you scheduled for a long time
andrew we had to get you back and i i
have to say that
to me president erdogan was very good
and i know they had you scheduled for a
long time and you were a very innocent
person
and he ultimately after we had a few
conversations he agreed
so we appreciate that and we appreciate
the people of turkey and you still
appreciate the people of turkey i
understand
right we love the turkish people that's
grace it's great to have you back andrew
thank you
please mr president thank you for having
me my name is sam goodwin i'm from st
louis missouri i was held in syria for
63 days
and uh i'm i think i speak for my fellow
former hostages and detainees here when
i say i'm as grateful as i've ever been
for anything to be home safely
and uh thank you for the information and
opportunity to be here
uh particularly ambassador o'brien was
incredibly supportive and helpful to my
family
and i can't say enough nice things about
him thank you for promoting him
and uh just really happy to be here so
thank you we got you back
you got him back yeah we got you all
back and we have some more that we're
working on right now to get back
that we better do please go ahead my
name is michael white mr president
i do once again it's an honor to be here
honored to meet you in person
basically what had happened with me is i
went traveled over to the country of
iran
it turned out there was a major major
trap and i was apprehended there
i went through a lot in their injustice
system and iranian justice doesn't iran
is an oppressive extortionist terrorist
regime you know what i'm talking about
but what you did sir you were able to
get me out of that prison in record time
it was amazing thank you very much well
thank you
please yeah my name is josh holtless and
my wife tammy yes
uh we were held hostage in venezuela for
two years i know very well
and you you helped us get out uh senator
hatch worked with you very well on that
as well
um and it was a a great honor to be able
to meet you right when he got back
i remember a lot of people ask me what
was like meeting president trump and i
just say i was
i was blown away i just got released
after two years then i'm shaking the
hand of the president in the oval office
i don't really remember a whole lot of
it
so it's nice to meet you again and it's
been great it's been great to be back
helping people through situations that
they've gone through and now we have
started our family well the great people
of utah really wanted me to do something
about the two of you
and we were able to do it and a little
bit of a miracle i think frankly
it was because it was a very hostile
period and
we appreciate everybody working so hard
with us but we were able to get you both
back and are you living in utah now i
hope we're solid that's good we'll say
hello to the folks in utah because
they're great people thank you very much
congratulations thank you
please i'm brian aaron spent an
unexpected trip there in
india i was not going to india i was
going through india to nepal
i've been working for the last 18 years
but on behalf of my family myself thank
you
president trump for getting us out and
getting us home
the darkest moment of our whole time
together
uh your letter to my wife came and it
really gave her the hope and the peace
and
from that time forward as more people
got involved especially the ambassador
there in
india things became more peaceful and
the hope
uh was there for the last four months
that we really wouldn't get to come home
because they had planned on keeping me
for three to five years
the original charge thing was three to
five years right and that was cleared
and then they came up with new charges
to do a seven year
uh term india responded very well to my
request
so we appreciate that and appreciate
everything y'all did
thank you all for being with us we have
a few more people we want to get back
and we will get them back and they'll be
back very soon
thank you very much appreciate it great
stories
hello my name is maximo alvarez
i live in miami florida not far from the
state of florida
which isn't just a 90 mile wide blue
strip on a map for me
it divides freedom from fear it divides
the past
from the press from the future
i know all about the past i'll never
forget my own
my family has fled totalitarianism
and communism more than once
first my dad from spain then from cuba
but my families don't run away by the
grace of god
i lived the american dream the greatest
blessing
i ever had my dad
only had a sixth grade education told me
don't lose this place you'll never be as
long against me
i'm speaking to you today because my
family is done abandoning
what we rightfully earned there's no
place to hide
speaking to you today because president
trump
may not always be politically correct
he's in fact
a successful businessman you know your
average career politician
our president is just another family man
a friend and most important
our elected commander-in-chief who puts
america first
keep in mind the other guy running for
president is mostly concerned about
power yes yes
power for them but not for the benefit
of all americans
i'm speaking to you today because
i have seen people like this before i've
seen movements like this before
i've seen ideas like this before
and i am here to tell you we cannot let
them
take over our country i heard the
promises of fidel castro
and i can never forget all those who
grew up around me
who looked like me who suffered
and starved and died because they
believe those empty promises
they swallow the communist poison pill
if you have a chance go to the freedom
tower in miami
stop and listen you can still hear the
sounds of those
broken promises
it is the sound of waves in the ocean
carrying families clinging to pieces of
wood
families with children who can swim
but willing to risk everything to reach
this blessed land
it is the sound of tears hitting the
paper of an application
to become an american citizen
most heard unlike the promises
but soon after they experienced the
reality
look at them listen to them
learn the truth those false
promises spread the wealth
free education free health care
defund the police trust the social
state more than your family and your
community
they don't sound radical to my ears
they sound familiar
and fidel castro was asked if he was a
communist
he said he was a roman catholic he knew
he had
to hide the truth
but the country i was born in is gone
totally destroyed
when i watched the news in seattle
chicago portland and other cities
when i see the history being rewritten
when i hear the promises
i've heard echoes i've heard echoes
of the former life i never wanted to
hear again
i see shadows i thought i had outrun
my parents only wanted one person
to decide my faith me
not somebody member not some government
official
not some bureaucrats in america
i would decide my own future i am so
grateful to america
the place where i was able to build my
american dream
through hard work and determination
president trump knows that the american
story
was written by people just like you and
i
who love our country and take risks
to build a future for our families and
neighbors
i may be a cuban born but i am 100
american
this is the greatest country in the
world
and i said this before if i gave away
everything that i have today
it would not equal one percent of what i
was given
when i came to this great country of
ours
the gift of freedom
right now it is up to us to decide our
faith
and to choose freedom
over oppression president trump
he's fighting the forces of anarchy and
communism
and i know he'll continue to do just
that
and what about his opponent and the rest
of the dc swamp
i have no doubt they will hand the
country over to those dangerous forces
you and i will decide
and here's what i've decided my decision
is very easy
i choose president trump
because i choose america i choose
freedom
i still hear my dad
there is no other place to go
thank you i made a good lord bless
america
the democrats are just going more and
more left many positive about socialism
liking it more than capitalism
many of the ideas we fought for that
were considered
radical are now mainstream the
compromise
that they came up with if implemented
will make biden the most progressive
president
uh since africa the radical left has
taken over the democratic party
and joe biden is marching in lockstep
with them
biden and the far left are promising to
crush middle-class families
with trillions in new taxes if you elect
me your taxes are going to be raised not
cut
promising amnesty and health care for 11
million
illegal immigrants citizenship for 11
million undocumented folks
promising to shut down energy
exploration killing jobs and hurting
america's economy
in joe biden's america the radical left
get whatever they want and you
get to pay for it they've already taken
over joe biden and the democratic party
don't let them take over america
good evening i'm nikki haley and it's
great to be back at the republican
national convention
i'll start with a little story it's
about an american ambassador to the
united nations
and it's about a speech she gave to this
convention
she called for the re-election of the
republican president she served
and she called out his democratic
opponent
a former vice president from a failed
administration that ambassador said and
i quote
democrats always blame america first
the year was 1984. the president
was ronald reagan and ambassador gene
kirkpatrick's words
are just as true today
joe biden and the democrats are still
blaming america first donald trump
has always put america first and he has
earned
four more years as president
it was an honor of a lifetime to serve
as the united states
ambassador to the united nations now the
u.n
is not for the faint of heart it's a
place where dictators
murderers and thieves denounce america
and then put their hands out and demand
that we pay
their bills well president trump put an
end to all of that
with his leadership we did what barack
obama and joe biden
refused to do we stood up for america
and we stood against our enemies
obama and biden let north korea threaten
america
president trump rejected that weakness
and we
passed the toughest sanctions on north
korea in history
obama and biden let iran get away with
murder
and literally sent them a plane full of
cash
president trump did the right thing and
ripped up the iran nuclear deal
obama and biden led the united nations
to denounce
our friend and ally israel
president trump moved our embassy to
jerusalem
and when the u.n tried to condemn us i
was proud to cast
the american veto this president has a
record of
strength and success the former vice
president
has a record of weakness and failure
joe biden is good for iran and isis
great
for communist china and he's a godsend
to everyone who wants america to
apologize
abstain and abandon our values
donald trump takes a different approach
he's tough on china
and he took on isis and won
and he tells the world what it needs to
hear
at home the president is the clear
choice on jobs in the economy
he's moved america forward while joe
biden has held america back
when joe was vp i was governor of the
great state of south carolina
we had a pretty good run manufacturers
of
all kinds flocked to our state from
overseas
creating tens of thousands of american
jobs
people were referring to south carolina
as the beast
of the southeast which i loved
everything we did
happened in spite of joe biden and his
old boss
we cut taxes they raised them
we slashed red tape they piled on more
mandates
and when we brought in good paying jobs
biden and obama sued us
i fought back and they gave up
a biden harris administration would be
much
much worse last time joe's boss was
obama
this time it would be pelosi sanders
and the squad their vision for america
is socialism and we know that socialism
has failed
everywhere they want to tell americans
how to live and what to think they want
a government takeover of health care
they want to ban fracking and kill
millions of jobs
they want massive tax hikes on working
families
joe biden and the socialists left would
be a disaster
for our economy but president trump is
leading a new era of opportunity
before communist china gave us the
coronavirus
we were breaking economic records left
and right
the pandemic has set us back but not for
long
president trump brought our economy back
before
and he will bring it back again
there's one more important area where
our president is right
he knows that political correctness and
cancel culture
are dangerous and just plain wrong
in much of the democratic party it's now
fashionable
to say that america is racist
that is a lie america
is not a racist country
this is personal for me i am the proud
daughter of indian immigrants
they came to america and settled in a
small southern town
my father wore a turban my mother wore a
sari
i was a brown girl in a black and white
world
we faced discrimination and hardship but
my parents
never gave in to grievance and hate
my mom built a successful business my
dad taught
30 years at a historically black college
and the people of south carolina chose
me as their first minority
and first female governor
america is a story that's a work in
progress
now is the time to build on that
progress and make america even freer
fairer and better for everyone that's
why it's so
tragic to see so much of the democratic
party
turning a blind eye towards riots and
rage the american people
know we can do better and of course we
value
and respect every black life
the black cops who've been shot in the
line of duty they
matter the black small business owners
who've watched their lives work go up in
flames they matter
the black kids who've been gunned down
on the playground
their lives matter too and their lives
are being ruined
and stolen by the violence on our
streets
it doesn't have to be like this it
wasn't like this in south carolina
five years ago
our state came face to face with evil
a white supremacist walked into mother
emanuel church
during bible study 12 african americans
pulled up a chair and prayed with him
for an hour then he began to shoot
after that horrific tragedy we didn't
turn against each other
we came together black and white
democrat and republican
together we made the hard choices needed
to heal
and removed a divisive symbol peacefully
and respectfully what happened then
should give us hope
now america isn't perfect
but the principles we hold dear are
perfect
there's one thing i've learned it's that
even on
our worst day we are blessed to live in
america
it's time to keep that blessing alive
for the next generation
this president and this party are
committed to that noble task
we seek a nation that rises together not
falls apart in anarchy and anger
we know that the only way to overcome
america's challenges
is to embrace america's strengths
we are striving to reach a brighter
future where every child
goes to a world-class school chosen by
their parents
where every family lives in a safe
community with good jobs
where every entrepreneur has the freedom
to achieve
and inspire where every believer can
worship without fear
and every life is protected
where every girl and boy every woman and
man of every race and religion has the
best shot at the best
life in this election we must choose the
only candidate
who has and who will continue delivering
on that vision
president trump and vice president pence
have my support
and america has our promise we will
build on the progress of our past
and unlock the promise of our future
that future starts when the american
people
reelect president donald trump
thank you good night and may god always
bless
america
good evening america i'm donald trump jr
we're here tonight to talk about the
great american story
to talk about this country we all love
this land of promise and opportunity
of heroes and greatness just a few short
months ago we were seeing the american
dream become a reality
for more of our citizens than ever
before the greatest
prolonged economic expansion in american
history
the lowest unemployment rate in nearly
50 years
the lowest unemployment rates ever for
black americans
hispanic americans women and pretty much
every other demographic group
and then courtesy of the chinese
communist party the virus struck
the president quickly took action and
shut down travel from china
joe biden and his democrat allies called
my father a racist
and a xenophobe for doing it they put
political correctness
ahead of the safety and security of the
american people
fortunately as the virus began to spread
the president acted quickly and insured
ventilators got the hospitals that
needed them most
he delivered pp e to our brave frontline
workers
and he rallied the mighty american
private sector to tackle this new
challenge
there's more work to do but there is a
light at the end of the tunnel
job gains are outpacing what the
so-called experts expected
but biden's radical left-wing policies
would stop
our economic recovery cold he's already
talking about shutting the country down
again it's madness democrats claim to be
for workers
but they've spent the entire pandemic
trying to sneak a tax break for
millionaires and democrat states into
the covid relief bill
then they attacked my father for
suspending the payroll tax for
middle-class workers
in fact if you think about it joe
biden's entire economic platform seems
designed to crush the working man and
woman
he supported the worst trade deals in
the history of the planet
he voted for the nafta nightmare down
the tubes went our auto industry
he pushed for tpp goodbye manufacturing
jobs
beijing biden is so weak on china that
the intelligence community recently
assessed
that the chinese communist party favors
biden
they know he'll weaken us both
economically and on a world stage
biden also wants to bring in more
illegal immigrants to take jobs from
american citizens
his open border policies would drive
wages down for americans at a time when
low-income workers were getting real
wage increases
for the first time in modern history
he's pledged to repeal the trump tax
cuts
which were the biggest in our country
after eight years of obama and biden
slow growth
trump's policies have been like rocket
fuel to the economy and especially
to the middle class biden has promised
to take that money back
out of your pocket and keep it in the
swamp
that makes sense though considering joe
biden is basically the loch ness monster
of the swamp
for the past half century he's been
lurking around
in there he sticks his head up every now
and then to run for president
then he disappears and doesn't do much
in between
so if you're looking for hope look to
the man who did what the failed obama
biden administration never could do
and built the greatest economy our
country has ever seen
and president trump will do it again we
will be stronger than ever because when
we put our mind to it
there is no obstacle that america can't
surmount
except there's a difference this time in
the past
both parties believed in the goodness of
america
we agreed on where we wanted to go we
just disagreed on
how to get there this time the other
party is attacking
the very principles on which our nation
was founded
freedom of thought freedom of speech
freedom of religion the rule of law
thomas jefferson famously said i have
sworn upon the altar of god
eternal hostility against every form of
tyranny
over the mind of man our founders
believed
there was nothing more important than
protecting our god-given right to think
for ourselves
now the left they're trying to cancel
all of those founders
they don't seem to understand this
important principle
in order to improve in the future we
must learn from our past
not erase it so we're not going to tear
down monuments and forget the people who
built our great nation
instead we will learn from our past so
we don't repeat any mistakes
and we will work tirelessly to improve
the lives of all americans
joe biden and the radical left are now
coming for our freedom of speech
they want to bully us into submission if
they get their way
it will no longer be the silent majority
it will be
the silenced majority this has to stop
freedom of expression used to be a
liberal value
at least before the radical left took
over
now the republican party is the home of
free speech
the place where anyone from any
background can speak their mind
and may the best ideas win people of
faith are under attack
you're not allowed to go to church but
mass chaos in the streets gets a pass
it's almost like this election is
shaping up to be church
work in school versus rioting looting
and vandalism or in the words of biden
and the democrats peaceful protesting
anarchists have been flooding our
streets and democrat mayors
are ordering the police to stand down
small businesses across america many of
the minority owned
are being torched by mobs the democrat
mayors pretend it's not happening
they actually called it a summer of love
and that brings me to another important
principle every
american must be free to live without
fear of violence
in your country in your communities and
in
your homes all men and women are created
equal and must be treated equally
under the law that's why we must put an
end to racism
and we must ensure that any police
officer who abuses their powers
is held accountable what happened to
george floyd is a disgrace and if you
know a police officer
you know they agree with that too but we
cannot lose sight of the fact that our
police are american heroes
they deserve our deepest appreciation
because no matter what the democrats say
you and i both know
when we dial 9-1-1 we don't want it
going to voicemail
so defunding the police is not an option
everything starts with safety and
security you can't have anything else
without it
you can't focus on building a better
future for your children without the
peace of mind
that they can study safely in their
classrooms play safely in their
neighborhoods
and sleep safely in their beds
but safety is only the beginning trump's
america
is a land of opportunity a place of
promise
i was fortunate enough to grow up in a
family that could afford the best
schools and the finest universities
but a great education cannot be the
exclusive right of the rich and powerful
it must be accessible to all
and that's why my dad is pro school
choice that's why he's called
education access the civil rights issue
not just of our time
but of all time it is unacceptable
that too many african-american and
hispanic american children
are stuck in bad schools just because of
their zip code
donald trump will not stand for it if
democrats really wanted to help
minorities and underserved
communities instead of bowing to big
money union bosses
they let parents choose what school is
best for their kids
they'd limit immigration to protect
american workers
they'd support the police who protect
our neighborhoods
they'd learn how to negotiate trade
deals that prioritize
america's interests for a change
they'd end the endless wars and quit
sending our young people to solve
problems in foreign lands
they'd cut taxes for families and
workers
they'd create opportunity zones that
drive investment
into inner cities in other words
if democrats cared for the forgotten men
and women of our country
they'd do exactly what president trump
is doing
america is the greatest country on earth
but my father's entire world view
revolves around the idea
that we can always do even better
imagine the life you want to have one
with a great job
a beautiful home a perfect family you
can have it
imagine the country you want to live in
one with true
equal opportunity where hard work pays
off and justice is served with
compassion and without partiality
you can have it imagine a world where
the evils of communism and radical
islamic terrorism
are not given a chance to spread where
heroes are celebrated and the good guys
win
you can have it that is the life
that is the country that is the world
that donald trump and the republican
party are
after and yes you can have it
because unlike joe biden and the radical
left democrats
our party is open to everyone
it starts by rejecting radicals who want
to drag us into the dark
and embracing the man who represents
a bright and beautiful future for all
it starts by re-electing donald j trump
president
of the united states thank you
and god bless america
i'm catalina lauf i work in the
political space
and i'm madeline lau and i'm the founder
of vegan health a children's nutritional
company
we grew up in a really small town
outside of chicago our mom's from
guatemala
our dad's a small business owner from
chicago and so
we brought two different cultures
together to create us
a little bit of crazy and um
a little bit of fun yes they taught us
the values of hard work liberty
to love this country unapologetically
our dad is a beekeeper and just had so
many different things out in the
countryside and it was just such a sweet
i grew up selling honey yeah at farmers
markets so
my line was uh have you ever been stung
by a bee but really it was
teaching us again entrepreneurship small
business
self-reliance and that we're the ones
that need to
put in the hard work to get what we want
my mother being from guatemala escaping
what she had there
growing up in poverty and
coming here to the united states being
able to fulfill her destiny and be
somebody that she couldn't there in her
home country
and they really instilled in us the
sense of
purpose but also self-accountability and
that
we had to strive to do the things that
we wanted and it was up to us to make
those things happen
in america there's no ceiling of
opportunity
you know you define your own destiny
through personal responsibility through
hard work
through having a moral value system
that's the american dream and president
trump's providing that for everybody
look at my business begin health as a
small startup that is growing and
launching
we are constantly trying to innovate and
the big challenge that kobe brought that
we just didn't see
coming was that just almost everything
kind of just shut down
and when you are a small startup and you
have limited funding and
the funding is really only to kind of
get you to that next milestone
we were really struggling and so we were
able to apply for a ppp loan which
really helped
allow us to continue hiring and working
and developing our products so that we
could ultimately still launch
it's now more than ever so important to
have a president and an
administration that understands that
small business
is the backbone of our economy tax
custom jobs act was huge
manufacturing deregulation fair trade
these are things that affected real
americans
we have a champion in the oval office
who has this business background he
actually understands the need for
small businesses like my sisters to
survive
we aren't the stereotypical conservative
i mean we're
we come from hispanic descent and we're
millennial women and that's not what the
media
wants and so somebody like
aoc alexander ocasio-cortez this far
left these women come out with
these very very destructive
political ideologies that are trying to
infiltrate
millennials and the next generation i've
decided to step up and say well we need
a counter voice to these women
there has been an assault on capitalism
just generally and i think it's very
scary to
imagine a biden world where the
progressive wing
ideas are starting to take front and
center stage
you know that will really choke the
american economy
there will be over regulation over
taxation
it's very hard to innovate through those
two things
and ultimately what's really sad is the
thought of you know making all of us
dependent on the government
and we are not going to allow that
i've seen a lot of moderates a lot of
people
now changing over because of everything
that's been happening
this is a taste of biden's america i
mean this the rioting the crime
freedom is at stake now and this is
going to be
the most important election of our
lifetime
we want to preserve the america that our
mother came here for
having a thriving economy that is
keeping america great
and president trump has delivered on
that promise
he's truly fighting for the american
people we're the greatest country in the
world
period on our worst day we're still the
greatest country in the world
and in order to preserve that it's by
putting america first having a thriving
economy
having happiness
good evening i'm senator tim scott from
the great state of south carolina
to all of you tuning in and
participating in the political process
god bless you this isn't how i picture
tonight
but our country is experiencing
something none of us envisioned
from a global pandemic to the deaths of
george floyd and brianna taylor
2020 has tested our nation in ways we
haven't seen for decades
but regardless of the challenges
presented to us every four years
americans come together to vote to share
stories of what makes our nation strong
and the lessons we have learned that can
strengthen it for further
generations because while this election
is between donald trump and joe biden
it is not solely about donald trump
and joe biden it's about the promise of
america
it's about you and me our challenges and
heartbreaks
hopes and dreams it's about how we
respond
when tackling critical issues like
police reform when democrats called
our work a token effort and walked out
of the room
during negotiations because they wanted
the issue
more than they wanted a solution do we
want a society
that breeds success or a culture that
cancels
everything it even slightly disagrees
with
i know where i stand because you see i
am living my mother's american dream
my parents divorced when i was seven
years old and we moved in with my
grandparents into a two-bedroom home
with me my mom and my brother sharing a
room
and one bed my mom worked 16 hours a day
to keep food on the table and a roof
over our heads
she knew that if we could find the
opportunity
bigger things would come i thought i had
to use football to succeed in life
and my focus on academics faded away
my freshman year i failed out i felt
four subjects
spanish english world geography
and even civics trust me though after
seven years in the senate i know i'm not
the only one in congress who failed
civics
but even while i was failing the ninth
grade my mother always said to me
timmy if you would just shoot for the
moon
even if you miss you'll be among the
stars
she never lost faith in me
even when i lost faith in myself
because of her encouragement i went to
summer school and caught up
the next year i met my mentor john moniz
a chick-fil-a operator
john saw something in me that i could
not see in myself
and started teaching me valuable life
lessons
like having a job would be a good thing
but creating jobs
would be even better that having an
income could change
my lifestyle but creating a profit
could change my community he planted the
seeds of what would become
opportunity zones this initiative that
the president and i work together on
is now bringing more than 75 billion
dollars
of private sector investment into
distressed communities
i took those lessons to heart and
started putting the pieces of my life
back together i realized a quality
education is the closest thing to magic
in america
that's why i fight to this day for
school choice
to make sure every child in every
neighborhood
has a quality education i don't care if
it's a public
private charter virtual or a home school
when a parent has a choice their kid
has a better chance and the president
has fought alongside me on that
later in life i started my own small
business
that's why i know it is critical for us
to have a tax code
that encourages growth we actually saw
revenues to the treasury
increase after we lowered taxes in 2017.
rest assured that democrats do not want
you to know that
after starting my small business and
spending some time in local government i
decided to run for congress in 2010.
the district is based in charleston
south carolina where the civil war
started
against a son of our legendary senator
strom thurman you may be asking yourself
how does a poor black kid from a
single-parent household
run and win in a race crowded with
republicans
against the thurman because of the
evolution
of the southern heart in an
overwhelmingly
white district the voters judged me not
on the color of my skin but on the
content
of my character we live in a world that
only wants you to believe
in the bad news racially economically
and culturally polarizing news
the truth is our nation's ark always
bends back towards fairness we are not
fully where we want to be but i thank
god almighty
we are not where we used to be we are
always
striving to be better when we stumble
and we will we pick ourselves back up
and try again we don't give in to cancel
culture
or the radical and factually baseless
belief
that things are worse today than in the
1860s
or the 1960s we have work to do
but i believe in the goodness of america
the promise that all men and all women
are
created equal and if you're watching
tonight i'm betting you do too
over the past four years we have made
tremendous progress
towards that promise president trump
built the most
inclusive economy ever
seven million jobs created pre-coveted
19
and two-thirds of them went to women
african-americans
and hispanics the first new major effort
to tackle poverty in a generation
opportunity zones we put hard
earned tax dollars back in people's
pockets
by cutting their taxes especially for
single parent households
like the one i grew up in cutting single
mothers taxes
70 percent on average president trump
supported these tax cuts
for those single moms and other working
families
and signed these policies into law and
our nation
is better off for it so
i'm going to ask you the american people
not to simply look at what the
candidates say
but to look back at what they've done
this election is about your future
and it is critical to paint a full
picture of the records
of donald trump and joe biden joe biden
said if a black man didn't vote for him
he wasn't truly black
joe biden said black people are a
monolithic community
it was joe biden who said poor kids
can be just as smart as white kids
and while his words are one thing
his actions take it to a whole new level
in 1994 biden led the charge on a crime
bill that put
millions of black americans behind bars
president trump's criminal justice
reform law fixed
many of the disparities biden created
and made our system more fair and just
for
all americans joe biden also failed our
nation's historically black colleges
and universities keeping blame on them
as they fought to ensure
our young folks had access to higher
education
once again to clean up joe biden's mess
president trump signed into law
historically high
funding for hbcus as well as a bill
to give them permanent funding
for the first time ever
and now joe biden wants to come for your
pocketbooks
unless of course you're a blue state
millionaire i'm serious
that's one of their solutions for the
pandemic they want to
take more money from your pocket
and give it to manhattan elites and
hollywood moguls
so they get a tax break republicans
however
passed president trump's once in a
generation tax reform bill
that lowered taxes for single moms
working families
and those in need so when it comes to
what
joe biden says he'll do
look at his actions look at his policies
look at what he already did and what he
didn't do
while he's been in washington for 47
years ladies and gentlemen
people don't always see those failures
because they think we're having a policy
debate on two sides of an issue
that is not what is happening our side
is working on policy
while joe biden's radical democrats are
trying to permanently transform
what it means to be an american
make no mistake joe biden
and kamala harris want a cultural
revolution
a fundamentally different america
if we let them they will turn our
country
into a socialist utopia and history has
taught us that path
only leads to pain and misery
especially for hard working people
hoping to rise instead we
must focus on the promise of the
american journey
i know that journey well my
grandfather's
99th birthday would have been tomorrow
growing up he had to cross the street
if a white person was coming he suffered
the indignity
of being forced out of school as a third
grader
to pick cotton and he never learned to
read
or write yet he lived long enough
to see his grandson become the first
african-american
to be elected to both the united states
house
and the united states senate in the
history of this country
our family went from cotton to
congress in one lifetime
and that's why i believe the next
american century
can be better than the last there are
millions of families
just like mine all across this nation
full of potential seeking to live the
american dream
and i'm here tonight to tell you that
supporting
the republican ticket gives you the best
chance
of making that dream a reality
god bless you and father please continue
blessing the united states of america
god bless
so
foreign
you